you are very agreeable when people ask
you for a selfie is that true yeah for
the most part I think I think that's the
way to be is it possible
sometimes you're too agreeable when
someone wants to take a selfie yeah yeah
we found one there's a guy who caught up
to you
while you were at a stall at a urinal in
a bathroom yeah and wanted a selfie and
we have it so I have to say I am very
nice I might draw the line there but you
look I don't know him well but I'm sure
there's better pictures of both of us it
was I was in a bar in Belfast I was
filming the fall or just filming the
five season of the full and those you
know peeing and because that's what you
do in the toilet yeah the states but
that's what we did yes eights we go
there to do our taxes yeah yeah anyway I
was peeing in this guy Simon he was like
oh my god my wife will kill me if I
don't get a selfie if you do mine I was
like can we wait like like two minutes
right it's for me two minutes
that's incredible yeah Boris I've been
drinking a lot sure okay so long yeah
got it
yeah okay I'm so he let me you know
finish up and then we took that great
great picture I love that picture that
shows that you're a nice guy and
hammered you can see this would gaze and
yes yeah I can see that at least wash
your hand I don't remember you know he
might I hope it was his phone yeah
you